and that seems to be the [ __ ] this week
there's a lot of [ __ ] lot of [ __ ]
drama
well no with everything I'm just saying
it was a drama packed week it was I
don't want to talk about the [ __ ]
keemstar h3 [ __ ] but I do want to talk
about the collar daddy [ __ ] yeah yeah
come on that's so good yeah yes so much
fun
following that yeah so much fun I just
you know I don't want to do a podcast
about podcasts you know but that one is
about business that one's about business
it is about business that drama is about
fumbling the bag big bag
they didn't even fumble it they were
they they got it they were in they they
got the touchdown and then it got
reversed so wherever the [ __ ] that's
called you know yeah I don't know sports
terms but you know let me take back that
you know I'm saying though here's what
happened they got the touchdown and they
did a celebration in the end zone that
was so flagrant that they got ejected
from the game and then suspended from
the team that's what it is
yeah totally it was what do you think
what it was a celebration they [ __ ]
after they got the touchdown they pulled
their pants down and and peed into a
t-shirt cannon and then shot the pee all
over the cup all over Bill Belichick and
they were like [ __ ] you we have the best
podcast in the world [ __ ] you were the
best quarterback receiving duo and if
you [ __ ] if you want us to do another
touchdown you better pay us all the
money and everyone here better make zero
dollars or we're gonna [ __ ] hit you
with PP again [ __ ]
and the revelant the ref was like that
was just lewd yeah yeah
so they got ejected from the game and
then they disappeared and then the coach
was like well I guess they're fired cuz
they won't come back to practice so I
don't really know what to do here I
don't even want to explain what happened
because you just got to go listen to
it's so good you got to go listen to it
but like we'll give I'll give you the
gist basically you know call or daddy
the podcasts which went from zero to
being like the big one of the biggest
podcast in the
in like four months and it's all because
barstool bought it and then helped them
blow it up and so all of a sudden it
became like this crazy pot you know
crazy huge podcasts about having sex
basically and you know the glut o'clock
nine thousand or whatever that's all
from that podcast you know so they blew
the [ __ ] up and then basically there was
a bunch of like contract disputes they
wanted more money people thought that
they were like continually saying on
their podcast about how little they make
and how much they're struggling blah
blah blah meanwhile behind the scenes
the CEO of barstools giving them half a
million dollars each a year saying they
still were not happy with that
and so yeah they like tried to
renegotiate a bunch of times basically
bonuses for downloads as well yeah so
they were making more than that and
there's they got merch and they got a
percentage of merch to which apparently
they were doing millions in merch and
they were taking dude and didn't they
have a beverage deal yeah I guess
there's some alcohol portion I didn't
know about that but yeah but if the mean
the throw fans were buying that but they
were easily making a cool M&M you know
probably probably they was looking like
an M&M pack and Alex yeah yeah yeah yeah
peanut M&M yes that is let me let me
quote the man Benny the butcher okay and
let me just you know if I could just
quote rap rap Bible chapter 7 verse
Grizelda keep talking while I find this
[ __ ] line so I guess now granted they
are one of the biggest podcasts they
probably get apparently they'd the CEO
of barstool said they'd make like a
hundred thousand dollars in advertising
revenue an episode off this podcast yeah
off his podcast which they've been
losing because the girls just stopped
doing it they just stopped coming to the
office and doing the podcast so now
every week barso loses a hundred
thousand dollars or whatever but if you
think about it that's like you know like
what half a million bucks a month just
on ads just on mid-roll ads so yeah like
if they had done this podcast
independently they they'd be making more
money that's why they're pissed
but it's like you signed a three-year
contract you just have to do it that's
what that's how contracts work and he
let them renegotiate a little bit to get
more money so like he was like here
listen I'll take six months off the the
end of your contract you can you can
leave six months early just just finish
it out so that we can have this revenue
for you know during the coronavirus
times or whatever and I guess they
started shopping the podcasts around and
they got another offer from another
place and so now they have no offers and
now it's just up in the air like what
the podcast like doesn't exist anymore
and basically the CEO of our still
posted an episode on on their podcast
feed which an was absolute insane move
so wanted so funny he posted an episode
that's just him explaining everything
from his side on their feet because they
own it bro so funny dude and and the
fact that you know there's like there's
a certain character that motivates it
seems like you motivated the whole thing
and it's just it's oh my god man that
what this like villain boyfriend guy and
HBO boyfriend guy it's just so it's
honestly team's fake it does it does
things like 10 perfect if we got got
whatever but if you haven't listened to
it I actually think it's a very good
example of you should listen to that
[ __ ] and listen to how bad some people
[ __ ] it up so you know in the future
if you ever get in a good situation
you're gonna go oh I don't want to call
I don't want to call her daddy myself
yeah I don't want to glug-glug myself
yeah you know if they did nothing they
were set to make what they would have
made like a million their first year I
mean he didn't say made like five six
million the next year and in and then
everything and then they get the IP back
that was one of the things the guy was
like listen I want to make this work so
here's the thing six months early you
can leave you get the show you can own
it again which you are still owns it now
you can own it you can do it
independently if they had just done that
and waited and it's not like waiting
with
that bad they're taking in the meantime
yeah oh
collect your million then go off and
make 10 Oh bro if they if they just sure
okay if they just played the game it
would have they would have made like
1520 million over three years
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and now
they're gonna make zero it's like why
would anyone know anyone this is how
contracts work yeah it's a it's it's a
little bit unfair but keep in mind there
was a 90% chance that your show was
gonna go nowhere and Barstow would have
been out money on you guys right you
wouldn't you could have just been
another average radio show that made
some money you know made back whatever
barstool invested in you in the first
place it's just by chance by luck a
little bit whatever yeah you get their
good but their [ __ ] blew the [ __ ] up and
now they're in this situation and they
think that contracts can just be like
it's like dude you're gonna get sued oh
man oh and bro the fact that they were
trying to go to legal battle with like a
massive corporate entity Oh get out of
here you know you don't have the [ __ ]
cash reserve barstool is pulling down
big money well I think the idea was that
they'd get whatever company they shopped
it to to pay the legal fees to get them
out of their contract Oh assuming they
make enough money to warrant you know to
cover that over the next couple years
with this new company right yeah but
then they didn't tell them that they
don't own the IP so then it's like it's
so entertaining honestly
so go listen to go listen to the caller
daddy episode
it's another thirty minutes yeah it's
like thirty minutes of him just
describing what happened from his
perspective like all the deals he
offered them and stuff like that [ __ ]
bonehead I've you know warning it's
probably gonna piss you off because
you're gonna listen to two people who
got an insanely good
just easy opportunity and they just
[ __ ] pp t-shirt t-shirt can into that
they did and it just got the ball
that's an ear I'm gonna try and do
sports terms here that was an easy lob
on the two yard line
yeah right yeah wide receiver wide open
looking at the ball oh he's good for the
wind yeah it's 58 74 yeah
58 59 yeah that's a football score right
yeah it could maybe it could be he's
looking at it oh and then Oh goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye and goodbye
goodbye unreal bro that's all I can
that's all I can say about it that's the
most intelligent thing I can say about
it because truly you can't believe you
cannot believe how bad somebody could
fumble the [ __ ] bag I was listening
so bad I feel bad for every party
involved I know I feel bad it's stupid
it's their own fault but it's like I
still feel I just millions just
evaporated just I have a hard time being
empathetic I have a real hard time being
empathetic
I don't empathize I just feel bad okay
all right you know no saying yeah I
don't feel about like oh they deserve
those milli whatever it was their own
mistake sure is that I just just a hat
just a bit for it to be there and now
it's not there anymore
yeah that's for everyone yeah it feels
bad but you know I can Wow [ __ ] Wow
you